today's money watch one day after
valentine's day we have a reality check
for you one study shows that nearly one
in five couples feel money is their
greatest relationship challenge and
about one-third say they're keeping some
type of financial secret from their
partner uh-oh
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger is here with some tips joe
good morning to you i'm actually
surprised it's only one in five people
who say money is their biggest
relationship challenge well i think part
of this is that you know what is your
relationship challenge changes from day
to day it may be that health has now
become the top concern of been a
pandemic but obviously finance is always
important in a relationship so when
should you have the conversation i have
to say that some of our colleagues here
at the show who are millennials tell me
that when they go on first second dates
they're talking about money and loans
and i was like what that's crazy so i
would say that's a little too soon for
me but what you try to uncover as you
get a little bit more serious with
somebody wanna know what are your
financial values right and what's
important to you and how much do you
feel confident about your own financial
acumen and what are some of the money
habits you have just little pieces that
will get you started people have varying
degrees they see things completely
differently
the big one for a lot of people is when
they get married or when they become a
couple are they going to combine their
finances yeah i really am agnostic about
this i have to say because i think in
some couples it works great when you say
let's put it all together we can do this
we'll assign tasks that's wonderful but
there are a lot of people who are both
working and feeling comfortable they
want to have their own money or as my
mother mrs schlesinger likes to say
what's his mind and what's mine
there is a point where you want to have
some control whatever you decide make it
a joint decision and if you're going to
assign tasks i want to be clear about
this let's say that michelle and i are a
couple and she says hey you know how to
manage money great okay but that does
not mean you can just be off the hook
i'm going to meet with you quarterly to
go through what we're doing here's what
our investments are doing here's how i
pay the bills you cannot be an
uninvolved partner to the point where
you don't understand the information why
do you have that look on your face
michelle no reason
well so here's the question though what
are the advantages to combining finances
with a couple okay the this is so i can
get vlad's wife on board let's be clear
okay you know because some people will
say it sometimes it depends on who you
bank with and perhaps i don't want to
pay the fees associated with the bank
that you uh shop with or or not okay so
the advantage is it's easier right
there's one account there's a master
account or a mistress account and you've
got it all paid but i don't have one of
those and on the other not that kind of
request
so the other hand i would say so in my
couple it's it's very easy we have a
house account and we both contribute to
that house account but we each maintain
our own accounts that could also be
because you know we don't have kids we
just have four-legged kids and there
aren't as many things that are being
paid jointly so i think again it's got
to work for you as a couple you've got
to articulate what you're doing and have
some ground rules so joe i recently
signed up for the automatic alerts every
time my credit card is used and i do it
to monitor fraud i don't want there to
be a problem so every i get a text
message every time something is
purchased so now i see everything that
katie purchases and i used to not
and it's created some conversations
these are not secrets revealed it's just
sort of things that were going on that
you weren't paying attention to so you
might need that
[Laughter]
all is good always happy but but like it
does raise the question of whether
certain secrets are okay or do you
really need to share everything with
everyone okay i think if there's like
some de minimis level some level under
which you've got free reign that's fine
come up with that amount it's a hundred
dollars it's 50 whatever works for your
couple however financial infidelity is
bad yeah and here's why because it can
really mask other problems underneath
the relationship psychologists say to me
one of the reasons we fight about money
and there is financial infidelity is
because underneath there is a larger
problem around trust that has not been
addressed so everyone come clean with
your spouses reveal those accounts be
sure you're on the same page do not say
anything to katie right now no i think
what you're saying is i think what
you're saying is everyone should have
those alerts on and then everyone knows
everything or you have or separate
credit we have trigger
[Laughter]
anything over 500
discussion a thousand approval
jill's lesson always great to have you
jill thank you very much